yeah I've been with a lot of uh
promiscuous gals in my day paid for a
couple of big old abortions that's a
thing you know I remember one time I
left the abortion clinic with a lady and
there's a guy protesting and he goes
you're a goddamn murderer I like I don't
know about murderer I really more just
hired a
Hitman he was like well if it was up to
me you'd be in jail I'm like well if I
go to jail for this I want murderer
status I want to look tough you know all
the guys are talking what are you in for
Grand Theft Auto assault and battery I'm
like murder they're like damn who'd you
kill I'm like a
relative they're like whoa why'd you do
that I'm like I caught him inside my
girl I missed that gal she was fun she
was wild even after the abortion she was
like hey we should celebrate with a
drink I was like ah I don't think you
should drink on an empty
stomach